[Musique]
une conférence de presse a été organisée
ce 21 octobre au palais de la source
afin de présenter un nouveau service
appelé à ses eaux un outil pour les
personnes sourdes et malentendantes qui
leur permet de communiquer sans frais et
sans rendez vous avec la mdph maison
départementale des personnes handicapées
là nous lançons cette application pour
les personnes malentendantes parfois
même soude qui bien évidemment ont du
mal à communiquer avec nos agents et
donc à travers cette application la mise
en place des accès aux et bien
l'accompagnement l'accueil sera
facilitée dans nos services pour les
personnes sourdes et malentendantes
c'est là une grande avancée parce que
dans une société qui se veut inclusive
nous ne pouvons pas laisser les
personnages en session de handicap
marginalisée
lorsqu'on les appelle de nos services
encore plus quand il s'agit de personnes
malentendantes ou souhaite donc voilà
nous lançons donc cette application
l'opérateur assez haut se charge de la
traduction entre les personnes sourdes
et malentendantes et les professionnels
de la mdph trois modes de langage de
communication s'offrent aux utilisateurs
de ce service tout le monde connaît la
langue des signes française mais il n'ya
pas que la langue des signes il ya aussi
le codage il y à aussi la transcription
qui sont des langages que les personnes
peuvent utiliser donc côté mdph nous
sommes outillés pour les accueillir à
tout moment avec les équipements adaptés
la personne pourra télécharger une
application sur son
smartphone ou sa tablette
il ya un flashcode c'est sur notre site
internet sur new flyer et sur nos
affiches mais une fois que la personne à
télécharger l'application elle cliquera
sur l'application choisira son langage
de communication et téléphonera la mdph
comme une personne entendante et le
dialogue pourra s'opérer de manière
aussi instantané que nous le faisons
avec les personnes entendent une
démonstration de l'outil a été faite à
l'occasion de la présentation officielle
d'accès aux antilles très attendue par
les personnes sourdes et malentendantes
conséquent qu'en métropole il ya
beaucoup de choses qui se sont hâtés
mise en place dans avec et l'accès ou
avec d'autres modalités d'accessibilité
ici à la réunion c'est le premier pas la
medefi hlm dépêche ouvre en fait cette
accessibilité avec la langue des signes
pour faciliter la communication des
personnes sourdes c'est vraiment génial
il faut que les choses bougent il faut
que ça continue
[Musique]
où
bon
[Musique]